خلص انا الان حاليا اعمل كربه اسره وحكيمه
قسم
طبعا من الصباح من الساعه التاسعه يتم
استلام الحالات كذلك بعد فتره الدوام او
خلال فتره الدوام احاول تامين الغذاء
لاولادي و ومتابعتهم من حيث امورهم
الشخصيه لكن هذا الامر
صعب من بدايه الحرب وانا لم انقطع عملي
ودمت اي وكانت ساعات العمل طويله كنت اترك
اولادي في البيت واتي الى عملي في مستشفى
غزه الاوروبي ف خلال ساعات دوامي في العمل
في هذه الفتره كان وجود اولادي لحال وانا
لحال تشغل بالي واكون يعني على الرغم من
صعوبه الفراق وصعوبه
المواصلات لم اترك عملي ثم بعد ذلك قررت
اني اخذ يعني اتي الى مستشفى غزه الاوروبي
نازحه انا وكل اسرتي
طبعا الارسال كثير ضعيف والانترنت اغلب
الوقت مش موجود حاولنا نساعد كثير من
الناس ان هم يصلوا لاهاليهم عن طريق ممكن
نعطيهم جوالاتنا انهم يتواصلوا مع مع باقي
الاهل او انه احنا نرشم لقسم الاستعلامات
كثير من الناس مع الاسف كانت تيجي وتسال
عن
ابنائها يعني الان اهلي نازحين في مكان
اخر عوبه التواصل معهم الاتصالات الضعيفه
لعدم وجود الانترنت في الاماكن النازحين
فيها هذا الامر
صعب الحياه التي نمر فيها يعني اتوقع انه
يعني بس ربنا هو اللي
مقدرناش البشريه للامانه يعني زميلتي في
القسم تعمل معي استشهدت كل عائلتها
اخوانها الذكور باولادهم
وازواجهم والدتها والدها كل البيت لا اثر
لا معالم لهذا البيت يعني انت خلال عملك
تفكر ماذا ساعد لاولادي الطعام من اين
ساجلب الماء من اين ساجلب
الخبز التواصل مع اهالينا كان اذا كان في
انترنت او اتصالات كان ممكن نتواصل لكن
باغلب الوقت الارسال هنا جدا ضعيف وما في
انترنت واذا كان في انترنت بيكون الانترنت
كثير ضعيف فبن حااول نتواصل مع اهالينا
لكن في النهايه انت لما بتطلع تدي خدمه
ربنا بيحفظك ويحفظ اهلك في النهايه والحمد
لله يعني بنرجع لاهلنا سالمين ان شاء الله
دائما كمان يعني احيانا كان يكون في قصب
حوالينا مستشفى اصابات من من الناس
النازحين حوالينا في المستشفى نفسها فاترك
العمل وابحث عن اولادي اللي في المستشفى
يعني كنت افكر احيانا اقول الحين الاقي
واحد من اولادي مصاب او شيء من هذا المثيل
هذه نكبه نكبه ثانيه للامانه لا توصف لا
يوصف ما نمر به الا انها
نكبه m